[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
das rezept für traditionellen und super
leckeren hormus hormus kommt aus dem
orient und besteht hauptsächlich aus
pürierten kichererbsen und sesam moos
und neben ganz vielen vitaminen
beinhaltet es auch noch magnesium eisen
und zink und ist damit super gesund wir
sparten ganz traditionell leben uns eine
schüssel voller kaltem wasser und geben
dort kichererbsen hinein
diese kichererbsen die mit ihrem bio
markt oder im türkischen oder arabischen
lebensmittelmarkt wir sind trocken und
roh also nicht vorgekocht und werden
jetzt zuallererst in dem kalten wasser
eingeweicht nach acht stunden oder in
meinem fall über nacht so bekommt ihr
die zeit schneller rum sind die
kichererbsen schon deutlich größer
geworden
desweiteren benötigen wir backpulver
zitronensaft joghurt hier habe ich den
zehnprozentigen genau wir können doch
gerne verwenden außerdem tine dass es
sesampaste gutes kaltgepresstes olivenöl
ganz wichtig ist auch knoblauch und an
gewürzen gemahlenen kreuzkümmel salz und
weißem pfeffer
die kichererbsen haben zwar schon
deutlich an volumen zugenommen und sind
auch etwas weicher geworden aber so sind
sie auf keinen fall verzehr bereit
begeben sie also zusammen mit dem wasser
in einen großen kochtopf geben da das
backpulver mit hinzu und lassen was
einmal aufkochen
anders als die meisten hülsenfrüchte ist
es besser erbsen so dass die in rohem
zustand giftig sind das heißt sie müssen
zuallererst lange gekocht werden bis wir
sie verzehren können den schaum der hier
entsteht nämlich mit einer schöpfkelle
weg und gäbe dann den deckel drauf und
lasse das ganze mindestens eine stunde
köcheln noch besser sind aber eine type
stunden nokia erbsen sorgen bei uns also
für übelkeit und bauchschmerzen
das darin enthaltene protein phase das
wird nach 20 minuten im kochtopf
denaturiert dann ist es also nicht mehr
gefährlich für uns jedoch lasse mir das
ganze länger köcheln damit wir sie
anschließend richtig schön pürieren
können
[Musik]
nach eineinhalb stunden sind die
kichererbsen fertig das heißt sie sind
schön weich geworden sind nicht mehr
giftig und ich nehme mir einige zur
seite für die deko der restliche topf
inhalt wird abgegossen und abgespült und
dann geht es auch schon weiter
[Musik]
in einer ausreichend großen schüssel
werden die tücher erbsen nun mit dem
pürierstab fein püriert die kichererbsen
können hier auch noch heiß sein das ist
gar kein problem und püriert sie so
lange bis keine stückchen mehr enthalten
sind und die eine richtig schöne passte
erhaltet
nun geben wir die termine mit hinz
weiterhin ist eine paste aus fein
gemahlenen sesam körnern und ist eine
grundzutat des humus und dadurch
unersetzbar anders als den juden ich
hier hinzufüge den joghurt könnt ihr
auch durch wasser ersetzen falls das
ganze vegan haben möchtet nun kommt noch
dass olivenöl mit hinzu und alles wird
noch mal fein püriert
[Musik]
ihr seht wir erhalten eine richtig
schöne helle passte und die muss nur
noch gewürzt werden
für den geschmack gebe ich hier noch
zitronensaft mit hinzu und hier müsst
ihr entscheiden wieviel zitronensaft ihr
in eurem humus am liebsten möglich nehme
ganz gerne für diese menge eine ganze
zitrone
nachdem der zitronensaft gut
eingearbeitet wurde und hier könnt ihr
auch immer wieder abschmecken so habe
ich auch gemacht gebt ihr salz und
weißem pfeffer mit hinzu der weiße
pfeffer sieht einfach schöner aus denn
den sieht man nicht ansonsten könnt ihr
auch gerne anderen pfeffer verwenden nun
kommen gemahlen der kreuzkümmel und
knoblauch mit hinzu zum kreuzkümmel
möchte ich euch gerne noch was sagen
denn wie ihr wisst sorgen hülsenfrüchte
für einen blähbauch und kümmel wird dem
entgegen und deshalb ist der kümmel auch
unverzichtbar
[Musik]
dem dann einmal abgespeckt wurde und mit
zitronensaft verfeinert wurde ist der
humus schon fast fertig
was die konsistenz des humus angeht so
könnt ihr das selbst entscheiden und
einfach mehr oder weniger joghurt oder
wasser mit hinzugeben bis in die
gewünschte seligkeit erreicht einige
mögen es gern etwas fester und die
anderen etwas flüssiger nun gehen wir
frischhaltefolie auf unsere schüssel und
lassen das ganze nochmals zwei stunden
kühlen damit sich die gewürze schön
entfalten können
nun wird das ganze angerichtet und hier
seht ihr ein beispiel ihr könnt das
ganze natürlich so gestalten wie ihr
möchtet
[Musik]
auf unserem traditionell angerichtet im
teller mit humus geben wir jetzt noch
olivenöl und hier ist es wichtig dass
sie einen guten kaltgepressten benutzt
[Musik]
darüber wird jetzt edel süßes
paprikapulver verteilt
[Musik]
zu guter letzt verteilen wir auf dem
humus unsere zurückgelegten kichererbsen
und geben anschließend grob gehackte
petersilie darüber
[Musik]
typischerweise wird muss mit arabischem
fladenbrot gegessen und hält sich im
kühlschrank drei bis vier tage
[Musik]
falls ihr jetzt auch lust habt auf
selbstgemachten humus dann schaut gerne
mal und wären die infobox da habe ich
nochmal alle zutaten für euch
aufgelistet
übrigens habe ich das rezept extra form
einer ramadan reihe für euch abgefilmt
denn humus solltet ihr nicht während der
fastenzeit essen das dem körper doch
sehr viel wasser entzieht falls ihr
keines meiner videos mehr verpassen
möchte dann hinterlasst mich gern ein
abo und ich sag bis zum nächsten mal auf
griechisch kitchen